hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar responsible science can you
trust your antibody presented by dr.
Anthony Covey own scientific manager
project manager and dr. Randy Wetzel
director of cytometry at cell signaling
technology
I'm Cindy Valdez and I'll be your
moderator for today's educational
webinar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by cell signaling technology
cell signal technology is a private
family-owned company founded by
scientists and dedicated to providing
the world's highest quality innovative
research and diagnostic products to
accelerate biological understanding and
enable personalized medicine before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also we will be
conducting some polls during this
presentation the polls will pop up in
your slide window and we would
appreciate your participation please
notice that you are viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits click on the button in the
bottom left hand corner and follow the
process to obtain your credit i'd now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
anthony cuvee on and dr. randy Wetzel
first dr. Cody on who has worked at cell
signaling technology for almost ten
years
he joined the company as a product
development scientist where he oversees
all the validation and release of over
100 different antibody products dr.
karubian
also led a team responsible for
generation of antibodies and kits used
for enrichment
of post-translational modifications and
they currently works as a special
project manager in the marketing group
where he is committed to guiding tsts
adherence to antibody validation
standards and practices Anthony has been
active in attending and presenting of
major meetings regarding the topic of
antibody reproducibility and works with
the subject matter experts antibody
users and csps
scientists to ensure that CST continues
to lead the field in antibody quality
and consistency our second speaker today
is dr. Whetsell who has been at cell
signaling technology for 15 years and
has currently leads the antibody testing
and validation team the antibody
conjunction team and an SI assay
development team specializing in eliza
bead assay and multiplex IHC tips
Rani's areas of expertise include wide
field confocal and spectral fluorescent
microscopy automated high-content
imaging
flow cytometry novel diet and
conjugation chemistry and sandwich assay
development please join me in welcoming
dr. cuvee Owen and dr. Whetsell
I will now turn the presentation over to
them welcome Anthony
and Randy thank you Susie this is going
to be a two-part presentation beginning
with myself
Anthony cuvee on and the tail end of the
seminar will be or the webinar rather
will be given by Randy Wetzel I'd like
to briefly introduce you to cell
signaling technology as Suzy mentioned
we are a private global company we were
founded by scientists and we focus our
efforts on application antibody driven
development especially focusing on
application specific validation quality
control and technical support cell
signaling technology has developed three
generations of in-house rabbit
monoclonal technology and over 95% of
our monoclonal antibodies are
recombinant almost all of the antibody
development manufacturing occurs at our
global headquarters and
Danvers Massachusetts under ISO 9001
guidelines and our mission statement is
to deliver the world's highest quality
research diagnostic and therapeutic
progress products that accelerate
biological understanding and enable
personalized medicine many of you over
the past few years have probably heard
or seen papers talk calling into
question antibody quality and cell
signaling technologies as we've
mentioned has committed itself to trying
to provide the highest quality reagents
available as a result of that we have
some pointers that we'd like to share
with you in terms of finding good
antibodies and how to validate an
antibody in other words how to trust the
reagents that you're using in the lab
the first I want to talk a little bit
about the antibody market that we are
specifically talking about which is the
research use only antibody market this
market has the most number of vendors
and those number of suppliers but is
regulated by the fewest number of
specifications in short there any
company in the research use antibody
market can offer any number of
antibodies and make any number of claims
with very little oversight currently as
of yesterday as a matter of fact there
are almost four million antibodies it
listed in the antibody research market
this is data from site AB about two and
a half million of those are polyclonal
and just over a million or monochrome
this is represented by a hundred and
fifty two different suppliers in other
words there's no shortage of research
use antibodies but how many of those are
good antibodies how many of those are
reliable in the assays that you're
trying to use in other words it's
important that you're not only using the
best antibodies but that you take steps
to make sure that you're validating your
antibodies prior to use when one thinks
about using an antibody it's important
to think about all of the different
properties that make a good antibody of
course you can consult the scientific
literature but as many of you know
trying to find out which reagents were
used by which individual investigators
it's not always a trivial task sometimes
investigators don't list the reagents
they used or they give incomplete
materials and methods sections producers
are guilty as well they don't often have
transparent data they don't show all the
validation data that they do if they do
validation data and often times
companies will resell the same product
from multiple different vendors and
oftentimes these reselling of antibodies
is not clearly documented there are a
number of search engines and aggregators
out there that store information about
antibody is available such as bio
compare and others and but these also
have very little transparency which ones
are ads which ones are real reviews it's
important that you understand what
you're looking at when you're reviewing
these antibodies you can also ask your
colleagues and your peers and this is
generally a great way of getting
information about which products work
the best but often times you're using
new reagents that nobody has used before
so a lot of times you have to take your
own steps in order to find it and select
a good antibody the upshoot is that if
you don't use a good reagent you're
going to end up wasting time and money
but most importantly you're going to
suffer a loss of reputation nobody wants
to retract a manuscript because the
antibodies that they use throughout
their manes their paper turn out to be
incorrect and nobody wants to be known
for publishing poor or weak data and so
it's important that you take the effort
upon yourself to make sure that you're
using good reagents every single time
you're doing an experiment and my
colleague dr. Whetsell
is going to talk in more detail about
the exact steps that you need to use in
order to do that in general i'm going to
share with you some things that that you
should do and think about it before
choosing an antibody
now what is being done there is a number
of efforts there are a number of efforts
ongoing currently in order to address
the antibody reproducibility problem
some of you may have noticed that
journals such as cell press and nature
and science and Olivia are actually
adopting new guidelines cell in
particular using the star methodology in
which authors need to clearly identify
every reagent used in a manuscript
including antibodies in many cases using
the research reagent ID or our ID
granting agencies and institutions are
stepping up training for investigators
postdocs and graduate students to make
sure that these individuals know how to
design and interpret an experiment
appropriately the NIH and others the G
BSI their global biological standards
Institute are also implementing
educational programs and increasing the
guidelines and standards around antibody
use and publication vendors are also
joining the fight in the sense that we
are offering greater transparency we are
doing more testing more validation than
we've ever done before
CST in particular has always prided
itself on its strong application driven
validation and we often provide as many
as much supporting information as we can
including reagents and controls an
award-winning technical support to be
able to help you do a successful
experiment on the other hand users can
always benefit for more education and
training making sure that they're
following the guidelines and standards
set up not only by the granting agencies
but also following protocols and
guidelines given by the vendors in other
words if you can't repeat the experiment
the way the vendor did it the antibody
was probably not valid to start with in
the end what's most important is for the
users to demand more and what I mean by
this is that you shouldn't just buy a
reagent and use it and if it doesn't
work don't say any call the vendor ask
why how they got their antibody to work
ask what conditions they validated under
it may be that it is a very good
antibody it's just not being used in the
correct way in general the following
things can be done you need to validate
your antibody in the model of the
application that you plan to use it it
nothing is more important than that you
should always also complete can include
a positive and negative model system and
additional to any experimental controls
it's CST we use the term binary models
and what this means is models in which
you're using it genetic positive
negative systems just a knockout of
CRISPR or you're using an inhibitor or
an activator to measure the specificity
of the antibody one thing that will
reiterate throughout this talk is that
using your secondary antibody alone or
doing a peptide block alone it's not
person specificity as Randi will
demonstrate when in doubt use the
protocol described by the vendor not all
antibodies will work in a general
protocol or your favorite protocol that
you use every day in your lab that's not
saying that the antibody is about
antibody it just means that the antibody
or the antigen is functional only under
a certain set of conditions it's
important that if you can't get an
antibody to work to use the vendors
protocol you still can't get it to work
then the vendor needs to justify why
they're selling that antibody and
whenever you get a new lot of antibody
regardless of how it was manufactured
whether it's a recombinant antibody or
polyclonal antibody we should test each
lot to make sure it behaves exactly as
you expect based on the previous law
prior to using it and again demand more
information from the vendors demand to
know how they validated the antibody
what the supporting data is what
applications it was approved of and how
it was tested again I've already
reiterated many of these things but I
want to make sure that we're super clear
on the idea that in the CST adheres to
is that we validate in every application
independently the idea being that
validation in one application one
particular protocol
not guarantee the performance in any
other application or protocol there are
exceptions to this rule but in general
the performance of an antibody by IHC
can give you some degree idea of how
specific the antibody is but it doesn't
tell you whether or not the antibody
will work for IHC for example antibodies
must always be validated in the desired
model system and application using a
defined protocol by both vendor and the
end-user in short the end user should be
able to replicate whatever it is that
the vendor has done much like a
scientific paper the first step that you
would do is try to replicate what the
other lab has done the same should be
true for antibody vendors all claims
should be supported by data I cannot
reiterate this enough as that vendor
should show all the data that they have
supporting the validations for their
products and again everything needs to
be validated between laws regardless of
how its produced and lastly even the
best antibody in when it's used
incorrectly can use incorrect non
reproducible results so what are the
things that you look for when you're
choosing a new antibody is it the number
and quality of citations is it user
reviews online
is it recommendations from a colleague
is that the data that you see on the
vendor website or the reputation of the
vendor is it previous experience if
you've had a bad experience with one
company do you go back to them again or
is it something else my recommendations
from having developed hundreds of
antibodies in my career is that what
those people are doing these days is
using Google or some version of Google
to first look for antibodies the hard
thing about this is that you can often
not tell what is being top-ranked based
on data or what's being top-ranked based
on advertising or keyword stuffing
literature is a great place to find good
antibodies again with the short coming
of the fact that not all materials and
methods are described well I find Saida
and bench SCI including lab own which is
now known as the validated antibody
database to be great sources of
literature based antibody information
there's also a number of user review
sites such as pad NAB's antibody and
even bio compare which have information
from users but they don't always capture
how the antibody was used or the all the
protocol information that one would need
to decide to whether that's a good
antibody or not you can also go to the
vendor sites and see what data they have
last of all you need to ask for labs use
lots of antibodies and many of the core
lab directors that I've spoken with keep
detailed records about the functionality
of their antibody antibodies they use
collaborators and colleagues are a great
source of information and as always tech
support ask about supporting validation
alternative methods that were used etc
for more specific examples I'm actually
going to turn the talk over now to dr.
Randy Wetzel who is the director of
cytometry here at CST Randy thanks
Anthony that was a great introduction to
the problem here what i'm going to talk
about is how we validate antibodies here
at cell signaling and hopefully you can
use this information to guide your own
antibody validation so we're starting
with this first slide which is a my
depiction of the five pillars of
antibody validation that was discussed
by pooling at all it really talks about
validating antibodies using a number of
different methods at the same time and
that's the strategy that we use at cell
signaling so we have a number of tests
that we do and I'm going to roll through
and show you some examples of each of
these so the first is staining positive
or negative cells or tissue this is
really one of the easiest and goes into
what Anthony described as a binary model
so in the top you're looking at flow
cytometry data and you see Fox p3
expression in the the t regs co-localize
with cd25 to confirm that in the bottom
we're looking at F cam expression in
positive and negative cell lines so this
is a great binary model we can also look
at sub cellular localization so often
that can tell you if a target is
specific or not if you know it should be
localized
say to them plasma membrane and UC
staying inside the cell or in the
nucleus then you know there's a problem
there we also look at tissue specific
expression so working in in frozen or
paraffin tissues looking at where where
the signal is in that tissue is it is it
in the Purkinje cells or is it in the
the mitotic cells in the testes so often
this can can help us determine if an
antibody it has non specificity for
signaling antibodies specifically we
look at different inhibitors and ligands
ways to to stimulate the pathways so in
the two pictures on the left this is an
EGFR antibody a total antibody and you
can see where EGFR is in the top left
picture in untreated cells and when we
treat the cells with EGF now you see
that receptor has been internalized
looking at the two pictures on the right
this is now phospho antibody so you see
there's no green stain in the top and
when we treat with EGF we see faso EGF
turned on note that these weren't the
same time that the one on the right is a
shorter time period we can also look at
translocations so here is Yap and you
see in local fluency yap is restricted
to the nucleus and as the cells become
more confluent you see Saito and nuke
and you might think that's kind of messy
stain I don't know if that's real but
you can see on the bottom there's a na-
cell line and there's no stains in there
we also concurrently test in multiple
applications so at cell signaling that
includes things like western blots I see
on paraffin icy and frozen sections
I see see flow cytometry so a lot of
different apps and the reason for that
is often one application will tell you
something that another one didn't for
example if I'm doing flow cytometry and
I'm looking at but there's no blood
vessels there's no muscle there's no
other cells the same with ICC so often
one application will find a problem that
the others can't see and so
having all these data together helps us
out quite a bit this is one example
where the Western blots actually looked
very clean these are real data these are
four different clones that we were
testing here with Western shown from
four different cell lines sorry oh yeah
four different cell lines and they all
look pretty specific but when you look
at the localization down below you can
see they're all very different some are
restricted to the nucleus some are
appear to be mitochondrial and different
mixes so this is a great example where
the combination of multiple applications
can really tell you a lot more about an
antibody knockout cells or tissues is
another great method so shown here is an
I HD stain we're on the top is wild-type
tissue and you see the RB p su H in
those bronchial epithelial cells and in
the bottom picture we have a conditional
knockout of RB p su h and you see there
is no stain there sorry only in the
bronchial epithelial cells peptide
arrays are another good way to look so
the example that I have for this is one
of the best ones I think is how do you
validate an epigenetic antibody that is
for example h3k27 trimethylation of
chemistry or imaging and see that it's
restricted to the nucleus you can look
on a Western blot and see that it's the
correct molecular weight for histone but
how do you really know it's tri methyl
and not mono methyl or dimethyl and so
we use peptide arrays for this where we
array out peptides with all the
different modifications and it's a great
way to quickly look and see which
antibodies are specific and which have
some preference for other epitopes or
even cross you know or cross reactive
with other sites you can also compare
stain to other antibodies or to RNA
detection so this the example I've shown
you is one where we're looking at three
different antibodies and you can see
that the localization is the same in all
three
with all three antibodies this kind of
lenss lens weight that you
antibody is correct the there's an
example now showing met so in this case
we were using formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded cell pellets that
either express meth like the two on the
top or do not express math like the
three on the bottom as you can see the
CFT antibody on the left is only
staining the positive cells and is not
staining the negative cells however the
other antibody on the right is light in
one of the positives and actually
positive in some of the negative cells
when this is then taking the tissue you
can see again nice clean membrane stain
like you would expect from net whereas
with the other antibody kind of mushy
stain that's that's all over and and the
localization does not match what would
be expected from that
another method is immuno precipitation
so in this case looking at the Tor
complex so if we I P with G beta L we
can then probe for and detect mTOR or if
we IP with mTOR we can probe and detect
rap door so it's another way to show
that their specificity based on your
knowledge of the protein interactions as
they as they are and they endogenous
systems two examples that are commonly
used and I think I would caution you to
at least understand the caveats one is
phosphatase treatment so you can treat
fixed cells fixed slides
fresh anything it with a phosphatase and
what this does is it completely
eliminates all phosphorylation and so
that if you had a faso antibody and you
think your tissue and treat with
phosphatase there should be no stain
there and if you do see and see stain
then that means your antibody is not
totally phospho specific but the thing
to remember is phosphatase is not
telling you that the antibody is target
specific only that it's phosphorylation
it's phospho x but you don't know what
that X is the other one is that I would
caution you about is staining
transfected cells the example shown here
is e ml four so I would direct you
toward the middle image where you see
dim but but definitely positive Basel II
ml for Express
in these HeLa cells you can knock that
down on the left with si RNA but note
what happens on the right if we transect
in EML for now only the transfected
cells look positive and you don't see
the dim stain so if this were truly
nonspecific stain but you simply express
the protein in cells you would you would
really see the transfected protein
because it's often at a high expression
and you would miss the nonspecific stain
that's there in the background as a rule
we try not to use transfected cell
models or antibody validation the last
two I think are not examples of
specificity blocking with the immunizing
peptide as you should hopefully know any
antibody will be blocked by the
immunizing peptide so whether it's
specific or nonspecific this is not a
good control and also omission of the
primary as Anthony mentioned it's a
great way to look at the tissue the
secondary reagents how much staining are
they having in the tissue but this
doesn't tell you anything about the
specificity of the antibody so I'd like
to go into some myths and yeah I created
the image of the unicorn with the
antibody antler I love that thing
so I'm gonna go through a few common
myths that we hear in technical support
first one if I buy an antibody from a
known vendor I don't need to worry about
specificity this is not true so here's
an example where you're looking at some
fossil earth antibodies and there was a
CSP in the Western blot on the left you
can see the CSD antibody and then to
competitor antibodies note that all the
nonspecific bands when we look at the
if' images on the right competitor
number two in this case was not
validated for if' so we didn't feel it
was fair to test that but competitor 1
was validated for four if' so we tested
that and you can clearly see with the
CSE antibody the on and off in treated
or inhibited and in the competitor
antibody it's just dim staying in both
conditions
another example here is it started in
our flow cytometry lab where we were
looking at two different antibodies for
faso step 5
and we saw a much greater signal with
with competitor antibody and so we
started to look into that and ran some
western blots as you see on the right
and note that very large high molecular
weight band this is typically seen where
we see receptor tyrosine kinases and so
then we took cells and treated them with
EGF and so what you see here in the on
the left is nice nuclear stain like you
would expect for phosphorus at five but
on the right that's clearly indicative
of a membrane protein most likely EGFR
in this case so this this antibody
appears to be cross reacting this
antibody is sold primarily for flow
cytometry so someone doing an experiment
with this might not know that this sis
antibody it's not specific the next myth
a good antibody will work in any
protocol hopefully Anthony founded this
message home protocol and sample type
are really critical so there are a
number of different protocols out there
this is a summary of a lot of them that
are used in imaging so there's different
methods of fixation permeabilization
diluents antigen retrieval all of these
things can affect antibody performance
so I'm going to show you an example this
is maybe a bit of an overkill we were
looking to optimize the staining
protocol for an LC 3 B antibody this
antibody should stain Auto phagosome and
so we set up a 96-well plate where every
well was a slightly different protocol
so the only thing they have in common is
they all have the same cells and the
same antibody but we vary the protocol
so on the Left it's one fixation method
on the right it's a different one and
then each row down is a different method
of permeabilization in different
concentrations so as I switch to the
image from our high content imagers you
should see right away already a
difference in signal from the left to
the right but maybe that's not specific
stain so we we dig in and look at all
the images and in the end chose one that
really improved the signal-to-noise so
our standard protocol is on the left 4%
formaldehyde with with 0.25 percent
triton and on the right is the optimized
call and you can see the dramatic
increase in signal here's the actual if'
image so you can't even see the auto
phagosome Zahn with a protocol on the
left but they're clearly visible on the
right and now this could be used in a
much more involved study so here you see
a few auto phagosome Zin untreated cells
Jakarta pean you see an increased number
la pyramide even more and as you would
expect chloroquine has the most so
tweaking the protocol really made this
antibody work well this is another
example with some stem cell antibodies
so the antibodies on the left middle and
red columns are all different pairs so
in red on the left is nanog and on the
bottom and on the green is trial 181 so
there are a couple different protocols
here dot Mac perm on the top and triton
perm on the bottom and you can see in
those left two images the trial 181 is
all bunched up on the membrane if you
would if you saw this hopefully you
would call cell signaling and say hey
it's not working and we would say we
know let's let's try a different
protocol try the dot Mac and you can see
for all of these pairs the opted for
trial 181 in the middle and the sox2 SSE
a4 on the right the the preferred
protocol gives the correct localization
there's another example of fixation
so you crosslinking fix it is like
formaldehyde and glutaraldehyde are very
good for most antibodies but some
notably the keratin antibodies do not
work well they actually do better in a
precipitating fix like methanol shown
here so you can see the stain is still
absolutely correct and and looks good in
the methanol this last slide on protocol
looks at a bunch of different Suites of
whether you're going to methanol fix or
methanol perm on the upper right
decreasing the formaldehyde
concentration or even changing the
blocking solution all of these can have
a dramatic impact on the antibody
performance so as Anthony mentioned it's
always best to go with the
vendor-supplied protocol first and make
sure everything's working and then you
can do your tweaks after often people
want to combine antibodies and multiplex
experiments
and sometimes the protocols are not the
same if you're unable to get at work I
would recommend give us a call we have a
lot of experience with this and we can
probably help you choose a protocol that
will work with the antibodies that you'd
like to use the next myth is a common
one an antibody that's validated in one
application or work in another in this
case ICC or frozen sections will work in
FFPE often you say you hear oh if it's
got a good Western then it'll work in in
IHC that's not true so this is a
wonderful antibody a p10 antibody shown
in the upper left staining human colon
and we also did formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded cell pellets and you
can see in a p10 positive cells on the
on the top it's nice nice correct stain
and on the p10 negative cells they're
negative however when we did you mean a
site of chemistry with these same cell
lines you can see that the p10 negative
cells also have stain so in this case
how the sample is prepared makes a big
difference in how the antibody will
perform the next myth is I treated my
cells with a ligand and I should see an
increase in phosphorylation but it I
don't see it the antibody must not be
working often when we hear this it's
more a question of where this where the
level of signaling is at a basal level
so you can see here in these c2 c12
cells if we serum starve them as on the
bottom you see very little stain and
when we treat with insulin you see lots
of sting and so in this case we've gone
from an almost off to an almost all on
condition and you can use as as I've
shown here next to off you can serum
starve
these inhibitors you can treat with
phosphatase and on the on side you can
use ligands and so this will give you an
idea of where your particular cells or
sample is in terms of offer on if it
happens to be say low here you might see
a good shift when you add a ligand
however if it happens to be already on
then adding a ligand is not going to
change it and this is a great example
I've shown on the right now this is a
p10 no
Ellen Capp cell line that without the
inhibition from p10 on the Akt pathway
you see it's just signaling like crazy
so if you were to take these cells and
treat with the ligand you would not
expect to see a change in signaling also
if you were to take away a growth factor
since this is is constitutively active
you would also not see a decrease in
stain so I think it's important to
understand what what the level of
signaling is similarly if you're using
antibodies that detect total protein
understanding what the level of
expression is in your cells another
common issue we have is customers will
call and say you know I can't I can't
see any signal with this antibody in my
cells and we look and it's a cell line
that doesn't happen to express that
protein or it's very low we use the the
so cell line encyclopedia at the brode
the ccle
this is a great database that the web
address is there on the bottom so from
this you can see things like RNA seek
data DNA copy number even protein level
front by mass spec so in this case we
use the ccle database to find a strong
positive and a good dead negative and
then we have another group sorry you 2os
cells in the middle that had moderate
expression the last myth I'm going to
talk about is is you can make weak
signal brighter by adding more antibody
this is a big no-no so antibody dilution
is determined by titration and the
optimal concentration of an antibody is
where all of the target is occupied by
antibody so if you're below that your
signal might be dim but if you go above
that since there's no more target to be
bound by the antibody you're only
increasing nonspecific signal so in the
graph shown here that blue is the signal
in positive cells and the red is the
signal in negative cells these were how
these were done on a high content imager
and if you look at the optimal
concentration you see nice clean
positive stain in in the positive cells
and very little signal in the untreated
net or negative cells if you were to go
to a higher antibody
concentration or a lower dilution you
would actually see a lot of nonspecific
stains so it's very important to work in
the optimal concentration of the
antibody and we provide all this on the
datasheet as a quick tip if you do want
to make an antibody brighter maybe
consider using something like Tyra minor
or another method of amplification so on
the left you see conventional
immunofluorescence with a conjugated
secondary used to detect that primary on
the right we're using an h RP conjugated
secondary and Tyra might in the presence
of h RP and and peroxide will bind to
the protein in that area in this case
Tyra might has been conjugated to a
green dye and so you're seeing an
accumulation of dye on the target
protein this can amplify your signal ten
to a thousand fold depending on how long
you let it run so on the left you can
see phosphor work this normally would
look great we've just turned the gains
down foot for to show the difference
between the two but you see the
difference between treated on the top
and untreated on the bottom note how
it's much brighter on the right with the
antyram I'd amplification another way to
improve your signal without changing the
anti concentration is to vary the
protocol maybe add in some antigen
retrieval this is very common in FFPE
sections but less often used in frozen
sessions but works like a charm so in
this case it's a hot boiling citric acid
antigen retrieval step really brings out
these shank 3 epitopes and in these
brain tissues so in conclusion I would
say proper antibody validation is
critical so whether it's offsets a
vendor or you as a user doing this you
know understand what what validation
means if someone tells you their
antibody is validated understand what
the protocol is what the sample is what
tests were done was it a binary model do
they did they really cover all their
bases if you don't see the data as
Anthony said definitely call and ask so
if you call cell signaling and you have
a question about an antibody a scientist
will help answer that question if it's
in a particular application like say
flows
by Tama tree you can call asked to speak
to someone in the flow cytometry group
and they'll talk to you through what was
done in the validation CFT provides
optimized protocols and validation data
for all of ours so we don't give you a
dilution range we tell you what the
dilution is based on a titration and we
have all the data to back that up
unfortunately we're not able to show
everything we have on a datasheet but
definitely give us a call and we can
share all that data with you and our
scientists as I said are here to provide
application-specific technical support
so if you need help multiplexing if you
need help working an antibody into your
experiment you're not sure quite how to
do it please give us a call and we'd be
happy to talk you through the protocols
so with that I'm going to stop and turn
it back over to you Susie thank you
thank you Anthony and thank you and
Randy for your informative presentation
we will now start that live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
audience members that you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and click the send button so
let's take a look at our audience
questions coming in first question why a
peptide block is not proof of
specificity that's a great question
thanks Rebecca I would say so an
antibody that's raised against a peptide
will bind to that peptide but let's say
the antibody cross-reactivity pnes if
you add the peptide to the antibody the
antibody will bind to it and will be
effectively blocked and now when you put
it on a tissue it won't be able to stain
that protein but also you won't see any
stain for the other 12 that it was cross
reacting with so it's it's a good way
maybe if you want to use your primary as
like an ISO type control on tissue
because you essentially take it out of
commission so it can't bind but even a
nonspecific antibody will be blocked by
the immunizing
and as a follow-up to that question
really the peptides can actually be used
as Randy described for determining the
specificity in a competitive assay so if
you want to know if your if your
antibody is possible specific outside of
the phosphatase you could actually do a
treatment where you use a modified
peptide versus the unmodified peptide
but only in the context of that kind of
assay is validation really useful for
determining the specificity thank you
and gentlemen if an antibody does not
list a method of authentic authentic
ated use how can I determine whether
this was tested and failed by the vendor
or whether it has not been tested that's
another great question so often you'll
see when an antibody is validated for an
application but I think what this person
is asking is what if you don't see it
how do I know if it's been tested that
we're trying to put that data out as
much as we can but in the short term
definitely you can call us most of our
antibodies have been tested on a number
of applications certainly all of our
monoclonal so we have data to support
that and and if you want to call us we
can tell you what test was done we can
share with you the data sometimes you
know it maybe if we tested it in in ten
different tissue models or cell models
we saw a problem in one and we'd be
happy to share that data with you and
show you what we have but right now we
only are able to show you the
applications that it does work in yeah
there's a another follow-up to that a
new tool that has been made available to
scientists that I think is really good
at determining in ways in which an
antibody has been used I mentioned in
one of my earlier slides a site called
bench side they actually pull literature
based use cases of the antibodies so if
you find an antibody from the vendor
that you're interested in or
looking for an antibody against a
specific target bench sigh and to a
similar degree side app do a great job
of telling you allowing you to filter on
the applications in which the antibody
was used and from there you can
determine the methods into paper so long
as they're listed obviously you can
determine the methods that the antibody
was used in and may be able to use one
of those methods with the correct
controls to use that antibody in your
experiment thank you and I also want to
remind audience members thank you for
your participation and your questions
coming in our next question what
recommendations for validation series
with a novel antibody in a new organism
another great question there's something
that plagues us often is I'll add to
that a novel protein where the
localization may not be known so the
first thing I would do working in
different organisms is maybe do a blast
search if you if you know the epitope of
the antibody and see how can serve that
that epitope is in the species in which
you're working probably a Western blot
is also a very good quick you know do I
see anything is it the correct molecular
weight there are other bands in there
after that I think if you know the
expected localization and you're pretty
confident about that then go ahead and
try staining that sample and see if the
expected localization is correct in if
certainly if knockouts are available
that's that's also a great way to show
that the antibody is specific great
thank you
our next question I've noticed that some
of csps
products don't appear to adhere to the
validation guidelines you discussed can
you comment on why this is the case yes
so this is an issue that we are
attempting to fix what I can say with a
great degree of confidence is that
almost 70% of our monoclonal products
have been validated using some sort of
binary model that includes a knockout
validation that includes plus and minus
treatment or inhibition part of our
limitation is our ability to display all
of the data that we generate on our
website in the in the development of a
product sometimes can take upwards of
two years we generate a huge amount of
information and until recently we have
done a relatively poor job with
collecting that information in one place
in a way that we can display it to the
user in an organized fashion but we're
actually working on fixing that and
certainly our scientists and our
production teams are more than happy to
share any information that we don't
display on our website with you if you
call I know that that's not an ideal
answer but sometimes that's the best way
to get insight as to how an antibody was
validated and how it was tested the
protocols used that the materials used
etc wonderful thank you we have time for
a couple of more questions from our
audience the next one I wanted to use
one of your products for IHC but it was
not listed among the approved
applications I did find a couple of
papers where the antibody was used for
IHC why don't you add this to your
approved applications list yeah and also
a common question people will say oh you
know you don't validate this antibody
but I used it and it stained by sample
or I see a publication there's a chance
that whoever used it in in that
experiment did everything correctly and
it is right but there's also a chance
that the antibody has an issue that that
maybe the researcher didn't realize
perhaps they themselves didn't use a
negative cell or tissue to validate or a
knockout they put it on tissue and it
kind of looked like they expected and
west forward I think the the bench side
website that Anthony mentioned is a good
way to look at where an antibody is and
in other papers but I would always be a
little skeptical look read their methods
and try to understand what they did and
how it's working
and then definitely contact us and ask
us why it's not validated so you know
perhaps we saw something in a cell line
that's not in your experiment or in a
tissue that's not in your experiment or
maybe we saw stain that as I mentioned
before if it's a novel protein and you
don't know where it should be
if you expect cytoplasmic stain but you
see something in the mitochondria and we
can't find a paper or anyone to show
that that is actually correct we would
err on the side of caution and not
validate it for that application yeah
and to follow up on what Randy's saying
is that that we have kind of three
levels of recommendation right we put
the application up with our product that
means that we validate it and we stand
behind it there are other two other
possibilities one that we didn't test it
because at the time we didn't think that
that application was important for that
particular target or we lacked the model
system to do it or we tested it and got
some sort of negative or inconclusive
results and so we have a large number of
products that you know looked great up
front but maybe there's some aberrant
staining that when Randy was talking
about that we don't fully feel
comfortable releasing that product and
so again calling in can help answer that
question because the teams can tell you
this is how we tested it these are the
results that we got this is why we don't
recommend it and there are cases in
which people will publish with our
antibodies and we do in an application
that we don't approve we actually do
collect that information but because we
don't support that particular
application we don't then show it on our
website however that does drive us to
then review so if a number of
publications coming out saying antibody
a was used in IHC that stimulates us to
go back and test it to see if we should
be supporting it in that particular
method so customers are our best friends
when it comes to crowdsourcing
validation information that we may not
be aware of
thank you gentlemen and do you test an
antibody in tissues or cells where the
target is known that to have very level
of expression yeah that's exactly what
we do so we wouldn't want to test an
antibody that has very high expression
of the target protein because you know
we then stamp our validation seal on
that what you're using in and sell a
tissue that has more moderate level of
expression you it may not work in your
hands so we want to look at ideally
something that's negative or very low
and something with you know sort of
moderate or endogenous levels of
expression we would avoid things that
are just very very high levels of
expression like the transfected models
but in generally we want to look at
normal levels of expression so to answer
the question yes definitely we want to
look in cells that have varying levels
of protein expression thank you
and gentlemen do you sell control vices
or slides that someone can use to
validate their antibodies in their lab
absolutely yeah
so we sell or for a number of our are
better selling antibodies we actually
sell extracts that we validate ourselves
they're used to do internally validate
so those are against our life aids we
also sell IHC control slides that can be
used not only to test your protocol but
also to test the antibody to make sure
that it's that they're working to your
as as advertised with this is an area
that we'd like to expand because it's
important to us that researchers can
have a successful experiment with our
reagents and so providing you the
controls and the other materials that
you need to generate that it is one of
our our top missions
and Anthony this has been a great Q&A do
you have any closing remarks you'd like
to provide for our audience before we
end today
yeah the one thing I will say and and
I'll speak before Randy in this case but
I would say that customers antibody
users are going to hear a lot of noise
about antibody validation and what
antibody validation means from vendors
from organizations from their own
Institute's and the bottom line is that
it is really important that you validate
the reagents that you're using in your
experiments
I spent some extra time in graduate
school using an antibodies that ended up
not being not being specific for the
target of interest and there's nothing
more demoralizing than the feeling that
you've been you know wasting time in
graduate school doesn't work so I think
it's important that people from you know
time and resource perspective make sure
that you're using the right stuff and
make sure that what you're listening to
and what you're hearing it makes sense
with practices of being you know using a
binary model testing lots a lot and
making sure the antibody works in the
application in the protocol which are
using are you beat oh good yes sorry
yeah I would also say the same be
skeptical you know look carefully at
those publications don't don't just
trust that that the validation was done
you know really dig into the protocol
and if you don't see something
convincing reach out to the person reach
out to the vendor you know I know we
would be happy to talk to people and
tell you exactly what we did and also
help help if there's a problem with one
of our antibodies thank you again dr.
Koo beyond dr. Whetsell for your
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
routes and cell signaling technology for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
audience members that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thank you so much for joining us we
hope to see you again soon
goodbye